hello everybody my name is Marc Lauren
I'm here again with Lord many in the
seventh know my name his name is way to
do sure whatever you want to call oh I
guess Science Theater is over now and
we're back to derp derp inton and the
the fro what is your name on our live
streams
besides dingo and the baby fro man in
the standard house it broke man in the
stache coming at you 92.5 am/pm cm and
DM all days is it why is this okay was
why is this floor so wibbly-wobbly it's
always like this somebody I heard into
the forums with somebody I heard I ran
in the forum someone was complaining
about the fact that the ground looks so
weird like this yeah I'm not sure why
that's the texture they chose to make it
but it is yeah it's not just a texture I
think it's the way that the things
freeform together when I was trying to
build a wall it was all sorts of
wibbly-wobbly anyway um I'm breaking
down the wood into planks okay what kind
of conditions your submachine gun in
it's in 50% I think all right I got a
it's a submachine gun in this suitcase
you can use to repair it
oh okay oh cool alright so then I
remember how to do this cuz you taught
me how to do it and I just dropped it on
the floor didn't I yeah my goal also
dropped all your wood planks that I just
picked up and put back in the suitcase
okay keep those there um you know what
to do with these more than I'm gonna try
to drop these rocks and I press Q but
apparently Q does not do it they're
behind you okay I'm dropping the rocks
you do with that with what you will I'm
going to weird my oh there it is okay so
now we get the submachine gun that I
have a 100% a thing submachine gun do
you want this pump shotgun cuz I know
you have one right oh sure yeah you can
repair with that one you know I've
actually I got another from your I got
another submachine gun let's go ahead
and give you the submachine gun and all
the ammo it's in the case here okay cool
and you keep the shotguns and we'll be
all cooperative and whatnot
alright do you see people we get along
long I have a lot of ammo for this gun
by the waist though we should be good
for a while
whereas I know all right so our
objective this time is to craft wallace
night and then i will go out and forage
more supplies clear out the bottom floor
or we'll go to an
other houses don't matter and then we'll
continue on and continue with our
adventure in this game trying to explore
the deeper aspects of it that is our
objective trying to get more into the
intricacies because that's what you guys
want to see question wait yeah do you
that's do you want to see that I want to
see dick jokes and fart jokes but this
is what my viewers wanna see no a
question do the zombies ever get harder
like as the days go by I feel like the
first day is always the easiest yeah and
from there it's hard to say I would say
with the name of the game being seven
days to die there's got to be something
there to it annoyed I've made it 14 days
oh okay you made it farther now yeah
okay and I mean it feels like once you
have a safe house yeah as long as you
repair and don't let them take it all
down each night yeah you're pretty much
safe okay but those boomers those
boomers have something to deal with it
okay I've got 60-inch scrap metal do you
want me to turn them into ingots um I
just made a pickaxe okay what do you
want to do during the day what do you
want to collect I will go to the houses
because I know there's a lot of
scavenger bulls out there so I just made
a pickaxe eventually one of us is gonna
have to forage over to the desert land
and gather saying okay um haha
I'd rather us go together for that one
we need a solid tree log not broken down
into planks okay uh SHhhh I broke it all
down all have fun I'll going one log I
think with a cloth fragment on top makes
a campfire Molly's really good at doing
all that stuff okay alright it's daytime
I'm gonna go clear at the basement Wow
Wow I just fall damage I didn't know
there was fall damaged
Howie that hurt a lot I'm gonna need
food by the way cuz I do not have food
um I got a little bit here I'll put some
in here no I'm already outside I'm
cleared oh but why do you mean it's
daylight okay I didn't know that oh
hello Wow sorry I just I forgot that we
run like crazy cycle he's not playing
with Molly anymore sorry I'm not trying
to stare at this zombie nurses cleavage
I'm really trying to loot her I
apologize
let's March it help for all that
appropriate this watch Wade's channel
four marks would if you know what I mean
yeah I swear these yeah god these are
these zombies they're laying themselves
out in suggestive manners it's
not my fault they kind of do honey that
is very true I need to take some
painkillers whistling good you die hey
whoa that got close thank you
Wow what that what was I gonna do I
forgot to kill this deer whoa oh hey you
have a Congo line behind you I think
it's a conga line
I believe aid yes I'll have they were
boiled don't you look stupid in front of
the internet yeah we make a living out
of that oh yeah that's very true huh
when you're right you're right wait I
can't argue with that
what do I do with bones can I make soup
out of them or something I'm not trying
to inappropriate look at this girl's
decayed cheerleader skirt yes
we just gotta I just gotta stick out of
her skirt Oh like intentionally like
toys with you oh I just killed a rabbit
I didn't even know there was rabbits
there yeah there are okay well if you
have like sticks and the rabbit meat you
can make like little kebabs or something
need to cook them uh-huh you need to eat
fire and like a cooking pot so
eventually we're gonna have to get a
campfire going because we do not have
that there's so much stuff to loot here
there's like ridiculous amounts of it
should they released a new Alpha a new
patch it's like the add more stuff yeah
I mean it's not like people are at a
loss to loot it's just that they're a
loss to survive I mean we could make
this like I don't know ten hour days and
just go through the day and never have
to deal with the zombies and then deal
with eternal darkness when that comes
but oh this isn't that it's not that
difficult in in my own my honest opinion
uh-huh got it
you're right there wait I'm good I was
having some trouble getting wood I don't
even need to say anything
that joke wrote itself every like
comment and subscribe if you enjoyed
Wayne's joke about himself there hahaha
it wasn't even oh god I said it wasn't a
Jew
oh really there Wade hey I found a
basement is this be good to start a mine
or something um well we tried that once
oh did not work out very well turns out
even if you try to mine underneath the
ground the zombies know exactly where
you are
oh so zombie and JP got trapped
underground oh it was fun time brutal
dead they were dead blood was everywhere
guts like you're the last person the
world I should tell this to but there's
TNT in this game oh really
I'm not that excited cuz I figured that
I'll never be able to make it and
without a zombie here to give me it with
his godlike powers I don't think we're
ever gonna get that's not here to give
it to you I've no I don't think I've
ever made TNT on my own I like in it you
know they're in as long as I've been
playing Minecraft I don't believe I've
ever made it on my own huh
anyway I found some more stuff I'm
mostly just more scrap metal nothing
bigger important just I'm out here
collecting a little bit of wooden some
rocks yeah okay I'm coming back cuz it's
about that time about that time again
Wade got a cuddle up in our bed share
body is is already gonna be over with
now shut up we're trying to get this
we're gonna make it just take off your
clothes and lie down on the bed which
else which my is which house the
question I'm asking which house are you
gonna take off your clothes and what he
didn't know house pretty much need a new
house at this point ah books damn it I
need III don't have a room for my fists
you know what I mean what all you say
room for Africa a room for my room why I
do not stay rooted funny everyone says I
say room funny but I do not that is the
robber you say room that is the proper
way to say room I'm going back to the
White House cuz that house didn't Lee
has a good attic fine whatever
you push a broom you stay in the clean
room you get uh oh uh way did it your
way out of here wait we need another
house like now it's just a blue house
okay blue house the blue house clear
please totally blesses clear probably
not but I got a gun and lots of bullets
all we get up the stairs here that's a
start that's an agreement I got a little
bit of wood left to block this off so
okay we'll be safe for another day it's
so full but after that I don't know you
normally we pick one house to hold off
and we just prepare it that way we can
use the backpacks and stuff to store our
items
uh-huh I don't play that Sneaky's I
don't play like that
that's how losers play games I don't
have authority Jim Utley it's true
teacher Merkley okay but wait I got the
bed down here you want hood I don't have
one you want to lay down on the bed I
got way too many bones here wait yeah
you do give what something just hit me
what oh I'm hungry I need food like
now-ish we need to cook make a fire I
got the Dennis ham right next to you
Graham whatever oh oh you're hurt so bad
oh please feed me shove it into my mouth
I shove that spam into my mouth oh this
is not work hey the can and all I need
water too
I'm not taking care of myself I
sacrifice it all for you waiting it's
that and I need Polly's help but I can't
[ __ ] is it a smart idea to make a
campfire in a wood building that was
worth for us yes great idea let it make
it so how do you make this well don't
you have a plan in your thing yes but I
don't know what the goes on top I'll
figure this out paper oh I don't even I
have paper here tada oh oh you had that
clearly on my own mark but if you're
watching my channel you know I had help
hahaha did Molly lean over and suggest
something to you
yeah she's I need to hearing it done
here huh for what for what wait please
elaborate
I got a laundry to do yeah I knew it
haha which you're whipped
absolutely cooking pot ah no but I have
venison look at his mother up in rack of
ribs here this bread down ribs oh you
want some you ought to share butter
sweet one oh you do
good let me just show this right in my
face oh I think I ate it oh my god I
hate it
so crap on it dude how do we cook it
it's not a cooking pot I believe oh
that's why I knew there was a reason for
the pots in the last few episodes
alright whatever I'm I've got 36 I'm
breaking down stuff hang on try to make
like six iron ingots okay I think I have
enough for that yeah I can definitely do
that I got ten iron ingots I did you
better okay good and then you should see
a thing for a cooking pot ah you're a
genius Wade you're a genius and only
needed six you douche so I said you said
five I'm saying no it only needed five
u2's I apologize I was wrong in making
fun of you Dada I know how do we do set
it down next to the campfire oh that's
not what you said okay there we go
happy alright um you're just gonna shove
it in your foot oh my god that looks so
weird look look at this how is this look
like some happen to me Asami scratched
me do I look okay wait oh hey okay we're
so messed up you're messed up shut up
how do you cook venison I don't even
know Oh No maybe um
look mate hang on let me take this let
me take the pot let me put the pot in
thing and then put their venison above
it no that didn't work Wow
uh I got a bone Shiv soon be arrested ya
know that know how you do launch is just
a knife ah plaintiff ah I got nothing i
got nothing was supposed to be above it
like it's just it's way it's way it was
intended to be look at that is that not
look right to you this magical pot
floating above the fire thank you thank
you thank all no s8 another roll gun
stop it stop eating all the venison I'm
gonna put it this box you suck at
surviving I'm doing pretty good you're
in that box I can't use the box when
you're using
okay let's just make this house our
house that we go to this all right how
do we uh what do we need we need to
start mining like that's what we need to
do can we dig out an underground area in
order to make can I have some sticks
please we need to reinforce this house
first they don't just get it and kill it
okay can I please have some sticks I
need to make a pickaxe and a fire axe
there's some stickier there's a whole
bunch of wood in here
well get your hand out of the bag thank
you there I don't even know how to make
sticks
maybe I literally just put the wood
planks in the middle shot that drop
plywood plywood then you get sticks
sticks I don't want all of it the fuel I
take all of it yeah by can you let me be
me how about you let me be me
cuz that never leads to survival how
about our you know what you're probably
right on that but I don't want to listen
to your sass anymore
I'm gonna go survive on my own
well it's 9 o'clock in the day already
so that's fine ok I got a how do I make
a pickaxe oh no what oh no what I'm just
getting a business
what I just like messing with you well
you do you did mess with him give me
good oh man would you go there I don't
have a son before darn good there yeah I
do I mess with you so good right Wade
right how do I make it oh there it is
pick it oh I need 5 or 6 or here there's
some more ingots in the suitcase no
actually I got just enough for a pickaxe
got it
boom BAM it boom BAM boom did it I did
it Wade I did it I did it I got a
pickaxe to the Fox and it's just so
happens to be day outside would you
happen to the house that we put a ladder
out is it no this is not that was the
house over on the other BAM yes oh that
hurts that hurts I'm gonna smack these
guys on the face with him fire blasts
key clatters whoa lady Bush looking good
in that dress
oh you're dead oh no idea what's going
on right now I'm a smacking ladies with
my axe Wow
it's not it's not wrap whoa whoa okay
watch out - I need to take some pills
all right
you want to clear these guys out me if
this is gonna be our house we're gonna
have to do it right oh wow way to go
Oh why do that oh that was an Ace
Ventura reference usually I like those
but coming out of your mouth it didn't
sound so good card cheerleader lady all
right we are actually all out of time
for this part there's so many zombies
all right so anyway thank you all so
much for watching I swear we're gonna
get to the more nitty-gritty of it I in
the next episode we got the supplies we
got the house for ready it's almost
gonna shut up so anyway thank you all so
much
can't you see we're trying to hurry you
oh those Sue's I'm honors but they had
bomb strapped to their chests
apparently so I can't help but speak in
a deep testosterone ladies boys while
I'm in here
can I throw a grenade on this wow wow
I'm gonna grit they saw all those
explosions the roof caved up above them
they're like Boom Boom down you get
annoyed
where'd you build it with you [ __ ] okay
Ken I'm okay
fam